well i was gonna do a different video
today but a lot of people started asking
me about whether or not marvel is going
to be losing characters like spider-man
and the avengers due to some of the
lawsuits of the creators families or
heirs as they are calling them
and let me clear this up for you guys so
that's we're going to talk about today
welcome back to the cosmic wonder i'm
your host warren and i don't think we
have anything to worry about let me put
your mind at ease now let's get right
down to this because i don't want to
drag this out or i don't want it to be
confusing for anybody we'll talk about
what it is and after i'll give my
thoughts on it so basically what has
happened here is that there are heirs or
family members of marvel creators like
steve ditko the co-creator of spider-man
and doctor strange and gene collin the
co-creator of the falcon and captain
marvel also detwiler is the nephew of
don heck co-creator of iron man and
black widow and detwiler is suing marvel
as well and there's other family members
that are related to the creators of
other characters like black widow and
basically what has happened here all of
these heirs all of these family members
have filed notices of termination they
filed these notices for the work that
their family members did on these
characters and basically what this means
is that these family members have told
marvel that you have until this time to
use these characters in your movies and
then we're done you can't use them in
comic books or movies anymore because we
own the rights to the characters for
example patrick ditko the brother of
steve ditko filed a notice of
termination and said in regards to
spider-man his termination notice gives
marvel until the end of june of 2023 to
use spider-man after that point in time
they can no longer use spider-man and
obviously this is where people are
starting to get really really worried
marvel could lose some characters here
and people are wondering and worried
about marvel losing spider-man some of
the avengers black widow iron man falcon
captain marvel and i get it i totally
understand everybody's worries these
family members are finally notices of
termination to where marvel can't use
these characters anymore it sounds
really scary however this isn't the
first time that marvel has dealt with
this creators and heirs of these
creators have done this in the past and
were not successful let me explain and
keep in mind i'm not talking about
whether or not i believe something is
right or wrong here i'm just going to
talk about the facts of law and cases
that have happened before in the past
now first of all heirs of creators are
allowed to do this under the copyright
act of 1976 heirs are permitted in
certain circumstances to terminate the
grant of a license or transfer to a
copyrighted work such as a comic book
via a properly executed notice and this
is what the heirs did but marvel has
already striked back and they actually
filed a lawsuit on friday against these
family members or heirs of these
creators and here's why you don't really
have to worry that much this type of
lawsuit has already happened before a
key case is involving jack kirby who
co-created the x-men thor and iron man
and the same thing happened jack kirby's
heirs sought to reclaim copyright to his
creations but the federal courts sided
with marvel finding that the characters
were made under work for hire
arrangements and due to the work for
hire arrangement it claims that the
heirs have no valid claim to the
copyrights basically what this means is
that marvel said these people created
these characters specifically for marvel
while they were hired by marvel working
for marvel therefore marvel owns the
rights to the characters they were
specifically created for marvel they're
marvels basically if i worked for apple
and came up with some sort of an idea
and then apple sold it it wouldn't be
mine it would still be apples if i
created a new type of ipad it wouldn't
just be mine i couldn't go off and run
my own ipad department it would still
belong to apple it's still apple's
product they still own it and that's the
simplest way to explain it really these
people's heirs jack kirby steve ditko as
great as they were worked for marvel
therefore the work that they did for
marvel belongs to marvel including the
characters that they created so this
case has literally been done before and
it was probably really scary before
family members filed a notice of
termination saying that marvel you have
until this day to use these characters
and then you no longer can but marvel
filed a lawsuit back in which they won
and the court of law sided with them
stating that marvel indeed does own the
characters because these people were
working for marvel under hire it's not
like marvel stole a character from
another comic book and claimed it as
their own before the other comic book
could release it marvel literally hired
people to create characters for their
comics and it's the exact same thing
that is happening here it is the exact
same case and that's actually what
marvel's lawyer daniel petrakelli said
he said it's virtually identical
circumstances family members are suing
for character rights that they don't
really have this is why we don't really
have to worry that much marvel has
actually been through this exact same
thing before and they came out on top
and they came out on top pretty easily
the work for hire case is pretty clear
and it's the exact same situation that
we're dealing with it's just more family
members coming forward about different
characters but the court sided with them
before and they can actually bring that
up as a case argument and considering
the fact that the laws are the same they
should win again no problem meaning the
heirs or family members don't have any
claims to these characters meaning they
can't terminate the use of any
characters meaning all of these
characters are going to be sticking
around in comic books and in the mcu and
this actually happened with superman as
well in 2012 a federal court ruled that
superman co-creator joe shuster's sister
could not terminate warner bros
copyright grant in the character due to
a 1992 agreement between the studio and
chester's heirs which prevented them
from pursuing termination now this one
was a personal agreement between warner
brothers and the creator and that's most
likely something that happened here with
marvel as well but again going to court
and stating the work for hire clause
kind of settles things right away they
were hired to create a character for dc
they created a character for dc so the
character is dc's they got paid to do
that work that is what they got paid to
do and again it's the same thing with
all of these heirs as family members who
created these characters they got paid
to create the characters for marvel so
don't panic i know a lot of headlines
right now are saying that marvel could
lose some of their characters i know a
lot of people are saying that marvel
could lose spider-man and the avengers
it sounds really scary but if we look at
the past and look at what marvel's done
we can be assured that it's going to
happen again and everything's going to
be okay now having said all this i do
understand where the heirs of the family
members are coming from and of course i
do think it's important to respect the
creators of these characters because
without them we wouldn't have these
characters if we didn't have stan lee
steve ditko jim starlin and any other of
these awesome creators we wouldn't have
these awesome superheroes and i think we
owe them a great thanks for that i
understand where their heirs are coming
from completely if my uncle was steve
ditko i would totally want the rights to
the character however and i can't speak
for them i wouldn't want the character
taken out of the mcu or out of a comic
book i want the character to live on but
of course i'd want to make some money
from it so i totally get where everybody
is coming from however the big thing
here is that we don't really have to
worry about marvel losing the rights to
spider-man or any of the other avengers
or other characters because that's the
big concern right now since marvel has
won this case in the past they are most
likely going to win it again especially
since they can bring up the previous
cases in the past and not to mention
warner brothers and dc have gone through
this as well and they rolled in their
favor as well so fortunately for marvel
and for us the fans the law is on our
side so we don't really have to worry
but let me know what you think about
this whole entire situation in the
comments down below don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all marvel news and don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof